le chocolat voilà salut vous avez vu
comme il fait beau aujourd'hui ça me
donne envie d'aller faire un pique nique
au soleil venez on va demander à
françois françois et françois tu dors
paraissait je me suis assis avec ce
soleil il fait si chaud aujourd'hui
mais justement on voulait proposer
d'aller faire un pique nique dans le
jardin à pic n'est pas une bonne idée
et d'abord on va demander leur avis aux
enfants évidemment me suis réveillée
enfin les enfants venez venez les voir
j'ai une très bonne idée est ce que vous
voulez qu'on fasse un pique nique un but
aussi
qu'est-ce que ça à un pique nique au
attendez moi elle et moi aussi je veux
dire on pique nique 1 et si vous voulez
je prépare à manger pour tout le monde
et ben franchement casimir je crois que
personne ici n'est vrai que de choisir
déplore par exemple qu'est-ce que tu en
train de préparer dans tombola la bague
lobby boulga et ben voilà voilà un bon
exemple de ce qui nous attend si c'est
toi qui choisis les plats vous savez ce
que c'est qu'avec l'oubli brega non il
veut si vous voulez je vous en prépare
un grand pour tout le monde
le cas pour tous voilà alors eh bien
franchement casimir franchement eux
explique à nos amis d'abord ce que
dumais danton gloubiboulga bon alors
voilà vous mettez 100 g de chocolat au
programme 100 g de confiture de stress
de bonne qualité deux cuillères de
moutarde ordinaire une banane écrasée
est une saucisse de toulouse tiède
tiens mais n'est pas cuite 1
chaque fois qu'ils parlent de tomber les
gars j'en ai mal au coeur dit ça vous
tente pour le goûter
non vous ne voulez pas c'est casimir
pour aimer le gloubiboulga il faut être
comme toi un gros monstre avec un gros
estomac mémoire go bon c'est vrai allez
on y va
tu te fous de casimir est bon mais il
faut pas tu sais on peut tu peux venir
avec nous quand même je suis sûr qu'il
ya des choses quitte les roues donc
ouais
est ce qu'il y aura de la glace à la
vanille fourré aux escargots a sûrement
pas non bon et et des épinards à la
crème chantilly avec une sauce à la mort
mais on tourne en rond mais vient quand
même tu ne t'ennuies rappaz vite et ya
quand même quelques petites choses qui
plairont elle est allée au niveau de
toute façon on va bien s'amuser 1
qu'est ce que vous voudriez manger si
vous aimez pas oublier que c'est bon ça
bah ouais je viens juste de terminer mon
premier bol de gloubiboulga mais tu sais
que j'en aurai bien manger un second
rang tu es vraiment trop gourmand voilà
françois qui arrivent il nous apporte à
manger à nous aussi
mais voilà j'arrive mais j'arrive
si je me suis fait mal aux la poupe
bananes des mangues lobby boulga aux
jeunes avaient perdu suis bien content
de la retrouver
j'espère qu'il n'y a pas à dire merci
casimir merci merci j'ai failli me
rompre le cou et toi tu trouves
qu'attaquer comme une banane ouailles
alors
alors moi je trouve ça exagéré mois pour
une vieille peau de banane mais mais
j'attends une peau de banane
quand j'ai fini mon goût bulgare je
grignote ça c'est très bon et bien c'est
surtout dans le panier qui doit y avoir
de la casse
[Musique]
la confiture de fraises qui est tombé
dans le chocolat roi de la confiture de
fraises avec du chocolat ou mais
d'écraser le saucisson vos du panier les
routes à castellon mais quid des
saucisses mélangé avec de la confiture
de fraise et du chocolat avec de la
moutarde et des bananes écrasées mais
c'est un gloubi boulga géant sa
formidable un gloubi boulga c'est joli
quel beau picking
[Musique]